Benji had been living in China for just three weeks when he was first invited to be on a Chinese TV show.
Benji 到中国才三周，就第一次受邀参加一个中国电视节目。
It's very easy as a foreigner to get on TV in some random way.
对外国人来说，以各种随意的方式上电视非常容易。
Yeah.
是的。
And it depends on what areas you're hanging out. Like if you're always hanging out at the malls, where a lot of foreigners are, where these scouts kind of hang out, then it can happen a lot. Once a week or once every two weeks.
这取决于你在哪些地区出没。比如，如果你总是在外国人聚集的商场闲逛，而那些星探经常在那里出没，那么这种事可能会经常发生。一周一次，或者两周一次。
Emailing with Americans in China in putting together this week's radio show, we heard about this kind of thing from person after person, people being approached to be on TV. And at some point we began to wonder, have you guys all been on TV? It was such a common experience for Americans in China. TV producers spotted Chidalia on a website where American expatriates hung out in the city of Guangzhou, a website called Guangzhou Stuff.
在筹备本周的广播节目时，通过与在华美国人的邮件交流，我们听到了一个又一个这样的人，他们都被邀请上电视。在某个时刻，我们开始纳闷：你们大家都上过电视吗？这对于在中国的美国人来说是一种非常普遍的经历。电视制片人在广州外国人常去的网站“广州玩意”（Guangzhou Stuff）上发现了Chidalia。
A girl kind of just saw my photo and she asked me if I wanted to be on TV. And just, of course, me without even really asking what the program would be, I just said yeah, sure. And they said, OK, come to the casting audition and I went.
有个女孩看到我的照片，就问我愿不愿意上电视。当然了，我甚至没有问是什么节目，就直接说“好啊，没问题”。他们说，好吧，来参加选拔试镜吧，我就去了。
The woman at the audition asked if she'd ever heard of American Idol. The answer was yes. But this would be for sort of a Chinese version called Super Girl.
试镜时的那个女人问她有没有听说过《美国偶像》。答案是肯定的。但这是中国版，叫《超级女声》。
And So I just asked her what exactly that would entail. Because I know American Idol is all singing, and I'm not a singer. Like not even a little. So I told her I can't sing. And she said oh, that's OK. That's no problem.
我问她这具体需要做什么。因为我知道《美国偶像》全是唱歌，而我根本不会唱歌。一点都不会。所以我告诉她我不会唱。她说：“哦，没关系，那不是问题。”
And so I'm thinking well, how is it not a problem? If this is a singing competition, the fact that I can't sing should actually be a really big problem. But they just wanted a foreigner to be on the program. [SINGING CHINESE SONG]
于是我在想，怎么可能不是问题呢？如果这是个歌唱比赛，我不会唱歌这事实应该是个大问题才对。但他们只是想让一个外国人出现在节目里。[演唱中文歌曲]
That's Chidalia singing on the program. She was kept through the early rounds of the competition while, she says, much better singers were bounced.
那就是Chidalia在节目中唱歌。她说，在比赛的早期阶段，她被留了下来，而那些唱得更好的人却被淘汰了。
I've often felt like a performing monkey on stage.
我经常觉得自己像舞台上的耍猴艺人。
That's Benji again. The four different Americans I talked to used the phrase "performing monkey" to describe the experience of being on Chinese TV. Benji's been on singing competitions as a judge and as a contestant. He's been on dramas in some pretty big parts. He's been on talk shows, which he describes this way.
又是Benji。我采访的四位美国人都用了“耍猴艺人”这个词来形容在中国上电视的经历。Benji曾在歌唱比赛中担任评委和选手。他也曾在一些大型电视剧中扮演重要角色。他还在脱口秀中出镜，他是这样描述的：
When foreigners go on TV shows, the most common thing is, they like to dress them up in old Chinese garb, like the Tang Dynasty clothes, and make them sing some old Chinese song and say some ridiculous phrase in Chinese. And then the host will come out and just kind of make fun of them or like talk back to them in a really bad Chinese accent, kind of like we-- which in America, if we were to speak to somebody back in their accent in English, it'd be considered kind of rude.
当外国人上电视节目时，最常见的情况是，他们喜欢给外国人穿上古装，比如唐朝服装，让他们唱一首中文老歌，再说几句滑稽的中文短语。然后主持人就会出来戏弄他们，或者用非常蹩脚的中文口音跟他们说话。这就好比我们——在美国，如果我们用这种口音跟别人说话，会被认为很不礼貌。
Like I've heard that in Chinese TV, the things that get the best ratings are children, animals, and foreigners, which just kind of says it all. It's just that foreigners are considered cute and adorable. It's kind of like a baby who can't take care of himself and needs to be loved.
我听说在中国电视上，收视率最高的是孩子、动物和外国人，这说明了一切。外国人被认为是可爱、讨人喜欢的。就像一个无法照顾自己、需要被关爱的婴儿。
Oh, so it's not ridicule. It's more like--
哦，所以那不是嘲弄。更像是——
It's more like oh, they're so cute. Yeah, oh look at that cute foreigner. He's trying to speak Chinese. It's so adorable.
更像是，“哦，他们太可爱了”。是啊，“噢，看那个可爱的外国人。他在努力说中文，真可爱。”
This is the treatment that foreigners get even when the subject is completely dead serious. Leif Rogers says that he's been on Chinese TV over 100 times in his seven years in China, mostly on talk shows, discussing charity fundraising for various causes that he organizes in his job at a Chinese bank.
即便在讨论极其严肃的话题时，外国人也会受到这种待遇。Leif Rogers说，他在中国的七年里上过100多次中国电视节目，大多是脱口秀，讨论他在中国一家银行工作时组织的各种慈善筹款活动。
I'm sure you've talked to quite a few people regarding this. I mean, right in the middle of a serious interview on a talk show about-- here we are talking about the victims of the earthquake in Sichuan, and then they'll say well, can you sing a song now? And then I'm like, no, of course I can't. And they're like no, no, no, you can sing a song.
我相信你已经就此采访过不少人。我的意思是，就在一个关于严肃话题的访谈节目中间——我们正在谈论四川地震的受害者，然后他们会说：“嗯，现在能唱首歌吗？”我就说：“不，我当然不能唱。”他们就说：“不不不，你能唱一首歌。”
And they'll name some John Denver tune or something that's popular over here. "Yesterday, Once More." And then they'll get the audience cheering and everything. And you know, no, I'm not going to sing a song here. Then they're clearly disappointed.
他们会点名要唱约翰·丹佛或其他这里流行的歌，比如《昨天，重现》（Yesterday, Once More）。然后他们会带动观众欢呼什么的。你知道的，不，我不会在那儿唱歌。于是他们明显感到失望。
Oh my. And are they doing that because you're a foreigner? Or they would just do that to anybody who's sitting there?
天哪。他们这么做是因为你是外国人吗？还是他们对坐在那里的任何人都会这样做？
The thing is, is a Chinese person would sing the song right away, no problem. So I think that it's more interesting when the foreigner does it.
问题是，中国人会立刻唱歌，没问题。所以我觉得外国人唱的时候更有趣。
It's more interesting when the foreigner does it. In the remote areas of China, lots of people have still never met or seen a foreigner. Though in the big cities, it's different. There's so many foreigners these days, that in day to day life in certain areas, they are not a novelty at all. Americans living in China who've been living there for years and years, no surprise, see things about China and the incredible changes in China going on right now that we here in the United States have never heard of, only have a hazy notion of, or just have wrong.
外国人唱的时候更有趣。在中国偏远地区，很多人从未见过外国人。虽然在大城市里情况不同。如今那里有太多的外国人了，以至于在某些地区的日常生活中，他们一点也不稀奇。那些在中国生活了多年的美国人，并不奇怪，他们看到了中国正在发生的惊人变化，而我们在这里（美国）闻所未闻，或者只有模糊的概念，又或者完全弄错了。
Evan Osnos arrived in China in 1996. And yes, he was asked to take a bit part in a Chinese movie his second month in the country. These days, he writes about China for The New Yorker. And he says he struggle sometimes to explain, not just in his writing, but to friends back home, what it is like to live in China. For instance, if you're living in America, he says, China just seems like this powerful, possibly threatening, world power, ready right now to dominate the world.
Evan Osnos于1996年来到中国。是的，他到中国的第二个月就被邀请在一部中国电影里客串一个小角色。如今，他为《纽约客》撰写关于中国的文章。他说，有时他很难向别人解释在中国生活是什么感觉，不仅仅是在写作中，还包括向家乡的朋友解释。比如，他说，如果你住在美国，中国看起来就像一个强大的、可能具有威胁性的世界大国，随时准备统治世界。
But actually, once you start to spend time in China or start to understand a little bit about how the Chinese see their place in the world, it becomes a lot harder to picture them thinking that they're ready to do that. And that's simply because the Chinese self-image is still in so many ways, very, very, very, very-- it's of a very weak country. They see themselves as being very weak.
但事实上，一旦你开始在中国待上一段时间，或者开始了解一点中国人对自身世界地位的看法，你就很难想象他们认为自己已经准备好这样做了。这仅仅是因为中国人的自我形象在许多方面仍然非常、非常、非常、非常……是一个非常弱小的国家。他们认为自己非常弱小。
There was just a poll that came out in the United States that shows that most people in the world, for the first time, now think that China is the world's most important economic power. Most people think that in Europe. Most people think that in the United States.
美国刚刚发布的一项民意调查显示，世界上大多数人首次认为中国是世界上最重要的经济强国。大多数欧洲人这么认为。大多数美国人也这么认为。
But in China, people don't think that. Only something like less than a quarter of the people they talked to actually think that China's an economic power in the world. I mean, even in the cities, the biggest cities in China-- Beijing and Shanghai and so on-- one in every three people doesn't have their own kitchen or toilet.
但在中国，人们并不这么认为。在受访者中，只有不到四分之一的人认为中国是世界经济强国。我的意思是，即使在中国最大的城市，比如北京和上海，每三个人中就有一个人没有自己的厨房或厕所。
So it's not to say that China's meek and that it doesn't want to make an imprint on the planet. Of course, it does. And it plans to. But its own self-image is that at the moment it remains a big, poor country with a lot of very, very poor people in it. And I think that's hard to picture from far away.
所以，并不是说中国很温顺，也不想在地球上留下印记。当然想，而且也计划这样做。但它自身的形象是，目前它仍然是一个人口众多、贫穷的国家，有很多非常、非常贫穷的人。我想从远处是很难想象这一点的。
Well today on our radio program, "Americans Living in China," what it is like to be there and what do they see, living there, that we don't see. They interpret for us this hour. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目《在中国的美国人》中，我们将讨论在那里生活是什么感觉，他们看到了什么我们看不到的东西。在这个小时里，他们将为我们解读。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际分发。我是Ira Glass。请留下来。
Act One. Why'd You Have To Go and Make Things so Complicated? There are about 70,000 Americans living in mainland China today, according to the Chinese and American governments. A lot of the Americans in China only stay for a few years.
第一幕。为什么你非要把事情搞得这么复杂？据中美两国政府统计，目前有约7万名美国人居住在中国大陆。许多在中国的美国人只待几年。
But then there are others, American expats who've lived in China for a decade or more, with no foreseeable plans to come home. Who are they? And how Chinese do they become? Evan Osnos has this story, which starts with an expat named Kaiser Kuo.
但也有一些美国侨民在中国生活了十年甚至更久，没有回国的预期计划。他们是谁？他们变得有多像中国人？Evan Osnos带来了这个故事，故事从一位名叫Kaiser Kuo的侨民开始。
Kaiser Kuo's parents were born in China. They lived through the Japanese bombing during World War II and then Revolution. They immigrated to the United States as teenagers and fell in love with each other and with the United States. They loved the Kennedys and the Apollo moon walk and Dr. Spock's child rearing books.
Kaiser Kuo的父母出生在中国。他们经历了二战期间的日本轰炸和随后的革命。他们在青少年时期移民到美国，相爱了，并爱上了美国。他们喜欢肯尼迪，喜欢阿波罗登月，喜欢斯波克医生的育儿书。
Their wedding photo shows a young man in Buddy Holly glasses and slick hair in an all-white suit, next to a beautiful young woman also all in white, standing together in bright, white California sunshine. They plucked Kaiser's first name out of an American book of baby names, if you can believe it. Kaiser's father, in particular, was smitten with America. Here's Kaiser.
他们的结婚照上，一个戴着巴迪·霍利眼镜、头发抹得油光光的年轻男人穿着一身白色西装，站在一个同样穿着一身白、美丽的年轻女人旁边，站在加州明亮洁白的阳光下。你可以相信吗，他们从一本美国婴儿名字书里选了Kaiser这个名字。尤其是Kaiser的父亲，对美国非常着迷。这是Kaiser。
My father told me once-- and really, it broke my heart-- he said he never touched his father until his father's funeral, when he finally touched his corpse.
我父亲曾经对我说——真的，那令我心碎——他说直到他父亲的葬礼，他才最终触碰了他父亲的尸体。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. They never embraced. I mean, I have this really affectionate family. I mean, we hug. We kiss. My dad always kissed us goodnight. I mean, I think this is part of their embrace of America. It's like, we're going to do things this New World way.
是的。他们从不拥抱。我的意思是，我有一个非常充满感情的家庭。我们拥抱，我们亲吻。我爸爸总是亲吻我们道晚安。我认为这是他们拥抱美国的一部分。就像是，我们要用这种“新世界”的方式来做事情。
The New World way meant Kaiser and his three siblings grew up with kickball, pool parties in the backyard, camping trips, a bad high school rock band. But all of that was constantly mixed in with stories about China. Their father kept a whiteboard next to the dinner table and sometimes wrote Chinese expressions on it during the meal. As much as they loved the United States, both parents never stopped missing China.
“新世界”的方式意味着Kaiser和他的三个兄弟姐妹是在踢球、后院烧烤派对、露营旅行和糟糕的高中摇滚乐队中长大的。但所有这些都不断地与关于中国的故事交织在一起。他们的父亲在餐桌旁放了一块白板，吃饭时有时会在上面写中文短语。尽管他们深爱美国，但父母双方都从未停止对中国的思念。
When the kids got out of college, China had begun to open up. And after so many years of learning about the country, three out of the four siblings moved to Beijing. They already spoke some Mandarin, and each of them became missionaries of a certain kind, for different parts of American culture.
当孩子们大学毕业时，中国已经开始开放了。在了解这个国家多年后，四个兄弟姐妹中有三个搬到了北京。他们都会说一点普通话，每个人都成了某种意义上的传教士，传播美国文化的不同部分。
One brother, Jay, was active in the early gay scene in Beijing. Mimi opened one of the city's first US-style yoga studios. But only one of the siblings has stayed in China to this day-- Kaiser, who brought rock and roll. It was his contribution-- part of it, anyway-- to the two generation obsession in this family-- the US, China, and how to build a life that straddles both.
其中一个兄弟Jay，在北京早期的同性恋圈子里很活跃。Mimi开设了该市第一家美式瑜伽馆。但四个兄弟姐妹中只有一个留在了中国至今——Kaiser，他带来了摇滚乐。这是他的贡献——至少是其中一部分——对这个家庭两代人的执念——美国、中国，以及如何建立一种跨越两者的生活。
Before Kaiser, for thousands of years in China, people had been listening to this.
在Kaiser之前，几千年来，中国人们一直在听这个。
[MUSIC PLAYING - CHINESE CLASSICAL MUSIC]
[音乐播放 - 中国古典音乐]
Or maybe some of this.
或者可能是这个。
[MUSIC PLAYING - CHINESE POP MUSIC]
[音乐播放 - 中国流行音乐]
Then along came Kaiser with long hair, head banging, and this.
然后Kaiser来了，留着长发，摇晃着脑袋，还有这个。
[MUSIC PLAYING - CHINESE ROCK MUSIC BY TANG DYNASTY]
[音乐播放 - 唐朝乐队的中国摇滚乐]
Kaiser was the lead guitarist and co-founder of a heavy metal band called Tang Dynasty, one of the first rock bands in China. A whole generation of Chinese kids, the ones who were interested in loud Western-style music, grew up with Tang Dynasty. By the mid-1990s, with Kaiser on guitar and his best friend, a Chinese guy named Ding Wu as lead singer, the band was huge, and getting bigger all the time.
Kaiser是重金属乐队“唐朝”的主音吉他手和联合创始人，这是中国最早的摇滚乐队之一。整整一代对大声西式音乐感兴趣的中国年轻人，是在“唐朝”的陪伴下长大的。到了90年代中期，Kaiser担任吉他手，他最好的朋友、一个名叫丁武的中国人担任主唱，乐队非常火爆，而且名气越来越大。
The number one song, stadium crowds. Kaiser sometimes looked out from the stage on 30,000 people singing back to them. People recognized him on the street. Things were great. Until May of 1999.
冠军歌曲，体育场人群。Kaiser有时会从舞台上看着3万人齐声跟唱。人们在街上认出他来。一切都很美好。直到1999年5月。
One morning, I wake up. And it's my brother, my little brother on the phone, telling me oh my god, turn on the news. The US has just blown up the Chinese embassy in Belgrade.
一天早上，我醒来。是我弟弟在电话里对我说，天哪，打开新闻。美国刚刚炸毁了中国驻贝尔格莱德大使馆。
China says it is outraged after 4 people die and 20 are injured, when NATO bombs hit the Chinese embassy in Belgrade.
北约炸弹击中中国驻贝尔格莱德大使馆，造成4人死亡、20人受伤，中国表示愤怒。
You may not remember this. But lots of Chinese people do. There's a Chinese monument to it in Belgrade. And the incident is taught in Chinese schools as an example of how superpowers like the United States-- and I'm reading here from a junior high curriculum-- put their interests above world peace and development and use their military advantage to attack whomever they want.
你可能不记得这件事了。但很多中国人记得。在贝尔格莱德有一个中国的纪念碑。这一事件在中国学校作为例子进行教学，说明像美国这样的超级大国——我这里是在读初中教材——如何将自己的利益置于世界和平与发展之上，利用军事优势随意攻击他人。
It was the NATO bombing campaign in Yugoslavia, intended to protect ethnic Albanians. And an American B2 bomber flying over Belgrade dropped five bombs on the Chinese embassy. Three Chinese citizens were killed. In America, people saw it as an accident. Not in China.
那是北约在南斯拉夫的轰炸行动，旨在保护阿尔巴尼亚裔。一架飞越贝尔格莱德的美国B2轰炸机向中国大使馆投下了五枚炸弹。三名中国公民丧生。在美国，人们认为这是一个意外。在中国并非如此。
My lead singer, my then-girlfriend, and I walked down to the embassy district to see what's happening around the US Embassy. And then everyone's there, shouting at us, saying hey, Tang Dynasty's here in solidarity with the people who are protesting against American hegemony.
我的主唱、我当时的女友和我走到大使馆区，看看美国大使馆周围发生了什么。所有人都在那里，对着我们大喊，说嘿，唐朝乐队来声援那些抗议美国霸权的人。
Of course, that wasn't my take on it at all. I was thinking-- I thought this through and said, this couldn't have been done deliberately. This must have been some kind of an accident.
当然，我完全不这么认为。我想——我仔细想了想说，这不可能是有意为之的。这一定是一次意外。
How did your band members react?
你的乐队成员有什么反应？
So initially, they kind of saw things my way. I laid out what I thought was a pretty reasonable case. But it changed really quickly.
所以起初，他们有点同意我的看法。我提出了我认为相当合理的论点。但情况很快就变了。
That very evening, we get a call from our manager who says, look, I'm going to get you guys on a plane tomorrow. We're flying you down to Shenzhen. And you're going to take part in this peace concert.
就在那天晚上，我们接到经理的电话，他说，听着，明天我会让你们上飞机。我们要飞往深圳。你们要参加这次和平音乐会。
[SPEAKING CHINESE (SHOUTING)]
[说中文（大喊）]
So they set up a stage in front of the whole thing. And they bussed in all these people who were wearing color-coordinated t-shirts that say [SPEAKING CHINESE]. Today China says no. And I realize that this is not a peace rally, that this is an anti-American rally.
他们在整个会场前搭建了一个舞台。他们用大巴载来了所有人，他们穿着颜色统一的T恤，上面写着“中国说不”。我意识到这根本不是和平集会，而是一个反美集会。
It's kind of the opposite of a peace rally, essentially.
本质上，这有点像是和平集会的反面。
So my hackles are up. And this camera swings into my face. And it's live, and I didn't know this either, at the time. And they ask me, you're an American. Tell me about your reaction to what's happened. And I said, I come here in the interest of peace. And I said, by peace, I don't mean just peace between the Kosovars and the Serbs, not just peace between the Yugoslav Federation and NATO, but also-- and most importantly-- peace between China and the United States after this tragic, tragic accident.
所以我火冒三丈。摄像机转向我的脸。它是直播的，当时我也不知道。他们问我，你是个美国人。告诉我你对发生的事情的反应。我说，我来这里是为了和平。我说，我所说的和平，不仅是指科索沃人和塞尔维亚人之间的和平，不仅是南斯拉夫联盟和北约之间的和平，而且——最重要的是——这场悲惨、悲惨的事故后，中国和美国之间的和平。
And at the word "accident," of course, everyone's face just blanches. The camera swings away. People start yelling at me. And then I can see that-- I figured that my band mates who were nearby me were mad because they immediately distanced themselves from me.
说到“事故”这个词，当然，所有人的脸都变色了。摄像机移开了。人们开始对我大喊大叫。然后我能看出——我意识到附近的乐队成员很生气，因为他们立刻跟我划清了界限。
I mean, we're on stage under this Styrofoam and wood mock-up of the burned-out embassy complex. And it's teetering. And when we finally get up there to play, the lead singer sort of looks at me, glowers at me and then starts saying today, the Chinese people will no longer be bullied by Americans. And [MUMBLES]. And he shoots me a couple looks. Now this is like my best friend for 10 years.
我的意思是，我们在用泡沫塑料和木头做成的烧毁的大使馆建筑模型下表演。它摇摇欲坠。当我们最终上去演奏时，主唱看了看我，怒视着我，然后开始说：“今天，中国人民将不再受美国人的欺凌。” 然后[嘟囔]。他给了我几个眼神。这可是我十年的好朋友啊。
The tension in the band got a lot worse. And Kaiser left, before he could be forced out.
乐队里的紧张气氛变得更糟了。Kaiser在被迫离开之前就主动退出了。
And the rage across China didn't die down. It got worse. Police were allowing students to demonstrate. The government was even encouraging protests, which are usually against the law in China. They grew into the most violent anti-American demonstrations in years. People set fire to the home of the American Consul General in the city of Chengdu and stoned the American Embassy in Beijing, while the diplomats barricaded themselves inside.
整个中国的愤怒并没有平息。它变得更糟了。警察允许学生示威。政府甚至鼓励抗议活动，这在中国通常是非法的。它们发展成多年来最暴力的反美示威。人们在成都放火烧了美国总领事馆的家，并向北京的美国大使馆投掷石块，而外交官们则把自己关在里面。
President Clinton apologized for the bombing, said it was a tragic mistake, the result of an outdated map. They'd thought it was a military office. Chinese television quoted his apology, but left out the part about it being a mistake.
克林顿总统为轰炸事件道歉，称这是一个悲剧性的错误，是过期地图的结果。他们以为那是一个军事办公室。中国电视引用了他的道歉，但删去了关于这是一次错误的部分。
For more than 100 years, China has seen itself as being bullied by foreign powers. And throughout the Cold War, when the US led the international fight against communism, the biggest bully was the United States. I've got a Chinese cartoon from the age of Chairman Mao that shows the following image-- an obese Uncle Sam sitting on a pile of money, waving a cigar at Chinese workers in a cage. There were images like that everywhere in the '60s and '70s.
100多年来，中国一直认为自己受到外国列强的欺凌。在冷战期间，当美国领导国际反共斗争时，最大的恶霸就是美国。我有一幅毛主席时代的中国漫画，显示了这样的图像——一个肥胖的山姆大叔坐在钱堆上，对着笼子里的中国工人挥舞雪茄。60年代和70年代到处都是那样的图像。
But that anti-American image had gotten a lot harder to sell after China went for the free market. And after the Chinese public had spent the 1980s and '90s falling for one Western idea after another-- Sigmund Freud, Ernest Hemingway, blue jeans, Hotel California-- the Communist party had been facing a kind of identity crisis. But then came the Belgrade bombing. And America the boogeyman came right back.
但在中国转向自由市场后，那种反美形象变得很难推销。在中国公众花费了80年代和90年代迷恋一个又一个西方观念之后——弗洛伊德、海明威、牛仔裤、《加州旅馆》——共产党一直面临着某种身份危机。但随后贝尔格莱德轰炸事件发生了。美国这个“恶魔”又回来了。
I have yet to meet a single Chinese person, to this day-- I mean, like somebody who hasn't at least spent their life outside of China-- who doesn't believe that this was a conspiracy, that this is a deliberate act.
直到今天，我还没见过任何一个中国人——我的意思是，没在国外生活过的人——不认为这是一个阴谋，是一个蓄意的行为。
That the United States deliberately attacked the Chinese embassy in Belgrade?
美国蓄意攻击了贝尔格莱德的中国大使馆？
That's right. I didn't get a sense for how enraged people were. And that was part of my mistake. I think that I was pretty cavalier about just how deep that stuff ran. The whole month of May of 1999 was actually the moment when I felt my American-ness.
没错。我没有意识到人们有多愤怒。那是我的错误之一。我认为我对事情的深度太掉以轻心了。1999年5月的整个月实际上是我感受到自己身为美国人的时刻。
For the preceding three or four years, I didn't have a lot to do with expatriates here. I didn't speak a lot of English. The women that I dated were Chinese. The life that I led was quintessentially Chinese. The vast majority of my friends were Chinese. That was a moment of incredible realization for me, that there's still a chasm that I'll probably never actually be able to cross.
在前三四年里，我与这里的侨民没有什么往来。我不怎么说英语。我交往的女性是中国人。我过的生活是典型的中国式生活。我的绝大多数朋友是中国人。那是让我难以置信的觉醒时刻，意识到仍然有一道我可能永远无法跨越的鸿沟。
That chasm is something almost any long-term expat in China encounters at some point. I know a guy from Texas whose moment like this came when the Beijing government bulldozed his barbecue joint. For me, it was year three, after I'd learned the language and moved into a Chinese neighborhood, where I loved not having to run into foreigners all the time, even though my job was to write about China for a foreign audience.
这道鸿沟几乎是每个在中国长期居住的侨民都会在某个时刻遇到的。我认识一个来自德克萨斯州的人，他的时刻是北京政府推平了他的烧烤摊。对我来说，那是第三年，在我学会了语言并搬进一个中国社区之后，我喜欢不必一直碰到外国人，尽管我的工作是为外国读者撰写关于中国的文章。
And then one day, this fax came into my office. It said, in Chinese, correct your misunderstandings or you and your family will wish you were dead. It turned out the fax was a response to articles some journalists had written about a recent uprising in Tibet. It was spam. Reporters got it whether they'd written about Tibet or not. But there it was.
然后有一天，这个传真发到了我的办公室。上面用中文写着：纠正你的误解，否则你和你的家人会后悔来到这个世上。事实证明，这封传真是对一些记者撰写的关于西藏近期起义文章的回复。这是垃圾邮件。不管记者有没有写过西藏，他们都收到了。但它就在那里。
That fax was so completely out of character with everything else in my life here. It made me embarrassed about all that effort to make myself as close as I could to China. It made me wonder if the enthusiasm was mutual.
那封传真与我在这里生活中的一切完全不符。它让我对自己为了尽可能贴近中国所付出的所有努力感到尴尬。它让我怀疑这种热情是否是相互的。
You get over these moments as an expat here. You go back to living with the knowledge that most of the time you'll be welcomed, treated with grace. But in the back of your mind, you know there will be another day, someday, when you suddenly find yourself an outsider.
在这里作为侨民，你会度过这些时刻。你会回到这样一种认知中生活：大多数时候你会受到欢迎，受到礼遇。但在你内心深处，你知道总有一天，你会突然发现自己是个局外人。
Mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi.
Mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi。
I'm going to get some water.
我去拿点水。
Kaiser's warming up for this weekly podcast he does. It's called Sinica, usually a lineup of expats in China, hosted by Kaiser and his friend Jeremy Goldkorn. He's South African, another long-term expat.
Kaiser正在为他做的这个每周播客热身。它叫Sinica，通常是一群在中国的侨民，由Kaiser和他的朋友Jeremy Goldkorn主持。他是个南非人，也是另一位长期侨民。
It's just for fun. It's not their job. Today, besides Kaiser and Jeremy, it's three journalists, including me, because I'm following Kaiser for this story.
这只是为了好玩。这不是他们的工作。今天，除了Kaiser和Jeremy，还有三位记者，包括我，因为我正在跟踪Kaiser拍摄这个故事。
Jeremy, you need to talk a little bit to make sure you're--
Jeremy，你需要说几句话，确保你——
I need to talk a little bit?
我需要说几句话？
Hey Dave?
嘿，Dave？
Am I talking?
我在说话吗？
Would you be able to grab me a beer?
你能帮我拿杯啤酒吗？
It's informal, clearly. We're all sitting in yet another expat's third-floor walk up in the Dong Cheng neighborhood in Beijing. Everyone here has known each other for years.
这显然是非正式的。我们都坐在北京东城区另一位侨民的步行三层公寓里。这里每个人都认识多年了。
I used to be a reporter in the Middle East. But in China, the expats are different. More of them speak the local languages and they don't expect to go to another posting every four or five years. They're usually here because they're interested in China specifically, not because they were drawn by the drama of a war or the perks of a place that's cheaper than home. They want to be in China.
我曾是一名中东记者。但在中国，侨民们是不一样的。他们中更多人会说当地语言，而且他们不指望每四五年就去下一个工作地点。他们通常在这里是因为他们对中国本身感兴趣，而不是因为战争的戏剧性或比家里便宜的地方带来的好处。他们想在中国。
Welcome to the Sinica podcast, a weekly discussion of current affairs in China coming to you from the pop-up Chinese studios here in Beijing. I'm your host, Kaiser Kuo.
欢迎收听Sinica播客，这是一个关于中国时事的每周讨论节目，来自北京的“Pop-up Chinese”工作室。我是你们的主持人，Kaiser Kuo。
Kaiser's 46, still has long hair, And his podcast gets as many as 10,000 listeners a week, mostly expats who've encountered him over the years, who have read things he's written.
Kaiser 46岁，依然留着长发。他的播客每周有多达1万名听众，大多是多年来接触过他、读过他文章的侨民。
After he left the band, Kaiser knew he couldn't continue trying to be Chinese. He was an American, a foreign expatriate, living in China. And he had to embrace that. And now after so many years, he's a kind of uber-expat in Beijing, a convener, a traffic cop who stands at the intersection of China and the foreigners trying to make sense of it. It's almost impossible to be a foreigner in Beijing and not hear about Kaiser.
离开乐队后，Kaiser知道他不能继续试图成为一个中国人了。他是一个美国人，一个生活在中国的外国侨民。他必须拥抱这一点。现在多年过去后，他成了北京的一种超级侨民，一个召集人，一个站在中国和试图理解中国的外国人交汇点的交通警察。在北京，如果你没听说过Kaiser，那几乎是不可能的。
Kaiser turns for an update to Gady Epstein, who's been in China off and on for 10 years and now writes for The Economist, which has just added a new part to the magazine, a China section.
Kaiser转而向Gady Epstein询问最新情况，他断断续续在中国待了10年，现在为《经济学人》工作。该杂志刚刚增加了一个新部分，一个中国板块。
Now I understand that this is the first time that your magazine has added a country-specific section since, what? 1942?
现在我明白这是你们杂志自1942年以来首次增加特定国家的板块，是吗？
Since basically about a month after Pearl Harbor. 70 years ago to the month, we started-- The Economist started-- its America survey, where we did we were devoting special attention to the United States. And this is the first time they've added a country since then.
基本上是在珍珠港事件后大约一个月。70年前的那个月，我们开始了——《经济学人》开始了——它的美国调查，我们投入了特别的精力去关注美国。这是自那时以来他们增加的第一个国家。
So what are we expecting from the new China section besides the arch and condescending editorializing that we've come to know and love?
那么除了我们熟知并喜爱的傲慢和居高临下的社论，我们对新的中国板块有什么期待？
Well, we are going to expand on our ability to be arch and condescending.
嗯，我们将扩大我们傲慢和居高临下的能力。
Ah, well, very good.
啊，很好。
We're also going to-- I mean, coincidentally with that, have more coverage of China.
我们也会——我的意思是，巧合的是，会有更多关于中国的报道。
The conversation moves on to what name The Economist will give its new China blog.
谈话转向了《经济学人》将为其新中国博客起什么名字。
We don't have one yet. We solicited people to nominate their own suggestions for the China blog.
我们还没有。我们征集人们提名他们自己的中国博客建议。
Most of them were pretty appalling.
大多数都相当令人震惊。
Really? What have you heard so far, Jeremy?
真的吗？Jeremy，你目前听到了什么？
Well, they were kind of like dragon and silk and--
嗯，他们有点像龙和丝绸，还有——
Well, I said we should please have--
嗯，我说我们应该请——
--bamboo curtain--
——竹幕——
--please have dragon, panda, bicycles and inscrutable, or some combination--
——请加上龙、熊猫、自行车和不可捉摸，或者某种组合——
The Inscrutable Pearl of the Oriental Dragon panda.
不可捉摸的东方龙熊猫之珠。
Sorry, too late. I've already taken that.
抱歉，太晚了。我已经用了那个。
So I think The Inscrutable Panda is not a bad choice.
所以我认为“不可捉摸的熊猫”是一个不错的选择。
How about the China Slant?
“中国偏见”怎么样？
You sent me a few of those, offline, Kaiser. And I was going to protect your reputation by not repeating them.
Kaiser，你在私下给我发过几个。为了维护你的名声，我没打算重复它们。
As foreigners living in China, especially ones who write about it for a living, we're always trying to figure out how to explain China, not just to our readers and listeners, also to our friends and family and acquaintances. We know that looking at the country from far away, for instance, from the United States, it can be difficult to make out the proportions here.
作为住在中国、尤其是靠写文章为生的外国人，我们一直在努力想办法解释中国，不仅是为了我们的读者和听众，也是为了我们的朋友、家人和熟人。我们知道，从远处看这个国家，比如从美国看，很难分辨这里的比例。
Parts of it seem very American, the friendliness, the conspicuous consumption, the drive, pride in the sheer size of the country and belief in the country's exceptionalism and the arrogance that goes with that. Also the ambition, and the anxiety among the ambitious, about getting your kids into the right kindergarten.
有些部分看起来非常美国化，友好、明显的消费、动力、对国家幅员辽阔的自豪感、对国家例外论的信仰，以及随之而来的傲慢。还有雄心，以及雄心勃勃者之间关于如何让孩子进入合适幼儿园的焦虑。
But then parts of it are straight out of the Cold War. We don't really have a good word for what China is now. Totalitarianism isn't right. But, of course, it's not politically free in any sense of the word. When I sit down to write, I'm looking at facts that are sometimes in direct contradiction with each other, and are also in motion.
但有些部分又完全是冷战式的。对于中国现在的样子，我们真的没有一个好词来形容。极权主义是不对的。但当然，它在任何意义上都不是政治自由的。当我坐下来写作时，我看到的客观事实有时是直接相互矛盾的，而且也在变化中。
Do I lead with the fact that the income of the average citizen here doubled in 12 years, a process that took 50 years in America? Or the fact that around 150 million Chinese people, the equivalent of half the population of the United States, still live on $1 a day? How does any expat answer the question, so what's happening in China these days?
我是不是应该以这个事实开头：这里普通公民的收入在12年内翻了一番，而美国经历了50年？还是以这个事实开头：大约1.5亿中国人，相当于美国人口的一半，仍然靠每天1美元生活？任何一个侨民该如何回答这个问题：“那么，中国最近发生了什么？”
So welcome everyone to Baidu. My name's Kaiser Kuo. I'm director of international communications here.
欢迎大家来到百度。我叫Kaiser Kuo。我是这里的国际传播总监。
Kaiser's job now, and for the last few years, has been spokesman for Baidu, which is a big deal. It's China's biggest search engine, basically China's Google. He's their English language spokesman.
Kaiser现在的工作，也是过去几年的工作，是百度的发言人，这可是件大事。它是中国最大的搜索引擎，基本上就是中国的谷歌。他是他们的英语发言人。
And here he's talking to a group of American MBA students. He does this sort of thing a lot in his job. It's an hour-long presentation that's part speech, part Q&A.
在这里，他正在向一群美国MBA学生演讲。他的工作中经常做这种事情。这是一个长达一小时的展示，部分是演讲，部分是问答。
--any questions you might have, feel absolutely free to ask whatever's on your mind. We are very much on the record. So anything that you can say, I will either try to weasel out of delicately or will try to give you the most blunt answer that I'm able to muster.
——如果你有任何问题，请随意提出来。我们是在公开记录。所以任何你能说的话，我要么会委婉地避开，要么会尽我所能给出最直率的回答。
Kaiser has to be delicate. His job has put him deeper inside a Chinese company than most Americans ever get. He's the face of one of the most important companies in the country, one that, in order to stay in business, works hand-in-glove with the Chinese government's strict censorship policies, meaning much of the time now Kaiser's speaking from the Chinese side of the chasm.
Kaiser必须小心。他的工作让他比大多数美国人更深入地进入了一家中国公司。他是这个国家最重要的公司之一的门面，为了维持运营，该公司与中国政府严格的审查政策紧密合作，这意味着现在大部分时间Kaiser是从鸿沟的中国那一边说话的。
Kaiser starts with the basics, explaining how big the Chinese internet is, much bigger than most Americans realize.
Kaiser从基础开始，解释中国互联网有多大，比大多数美国人意识到的要大得多。
By last count, a whopping 513 million people using the internet in China.
据最新统计，中国互联网用户高达5.13亿。
That's more than the US, Canada, and Mexico combined. And since Americans often mistakenly think Baidu is a government-owned and run company-- it's not-- Kaiser talks about how Baidu is a private company. It's dominated not only every American search engine that's tried to muscle in, but also recent attempts by the Chinese government to create a state-run competitor.
这比美国、加拿大和墨西哥加起来还要多。由于美国人经常错误地认为百度是一家政府拥有和运营的公司——其实不是——Kaiser谈到了百度是如何成为一家私营公司的。它不仅击败了所有试图挤进来的美国搜索引擎，也击败了中国政府最近试图建立的国有竞争对手。
On a big screen, with help from his colleague, Betty, he does searches and shows some of Baidu's features. And then at some point, he gets the question, the one he always gets from foreigners.
在大屏幕上，在他的同事Betty的帮助下，他进行搜索并展示了百度的功能。然后，他收到了那个问题，那个他总是从外国人那里收到的问题。
Yes? In the back. Oh wait, you had a question.
是的？后面的那位。哦等等，你有个问题。
I did. So we're staying at the Crowne Plaza. And when you log on to the internet, it says no Facebook, no YouTube, and I don't remember what else it said.
我有。我们住在皇冠假日酒店。当你登录互联网时，上面显示没有Facebook，没有YouTube，我不记得它还说了什么。
Twitter.
Twitter。
Probably Twitter.
可能是Twitter。
Sure.
当然。
And correct me if I'm wrong, it's kind of-- what it appears to me that you guys have done, is kind of integrate those into your search. So she was able to find a video on Coldplay, which it was almost like a YouTube video. Do you guys really try to kind of push the limit against kind of what Big Brother tells you to do? How much power do you have to say--
如果我没记错的话，这有点——在我看来你们所做的是把那些整合到你们的搜索中。所以她能找到关于酷玩乐队的视频，几乎就像YouTube视频一样。你们真的试图违抗“老大哥”告诉你们要做的事情吗？你们有多少权力去说——
Let me put it this way--
让我这样说吧——
--no guys, let's look at this.
——不，伙计们，让我们看看这个。
Like I told this gentlemen here, we are a consumer-facing company, so we do not labor on the illusion that they want to have, as you say, Big Brother telling them what they can and cannot see. So our interest is in providing the consumers with exactly what they want. Our interests are also with abiding by the law. So we have a line to walk. This gentleman over here had a question.
就像我告诉这位先生的那样，我们是一家面向消费者的公司，所以我们并不抱有幻想，以为他们想要像你所说的那样，有“老大哥”来告诉他们能看什么、不能看什么。所以我们的兴趣是为消费者提供他们想要的。我们的兴趣也在于遵守法律。所以我们有一条底线要走。这位先生有个问题。
Internet censorship in China comes in a bunch of different forms. Let's say you go to Google, which you can still do in China, even though they famously pulled out years ago. They just relocated most of their servers to Hong Kong, which has different censorship laws.
中国的互联网审查有多种形式。假设你使用谷歌，即便他们几年前著名地撤出了，你仍然可以在中国使用。他们只是把大部分服务器迁到了拥有不同审查法的香港。
So if you're in Beijing and you go on Google and enter a sensitive search term, for instance, Tiananmen Square, you'll get a full set of search results. But if you try to click on any of the links that the government is blocking, then your computer will get weirdly slow. And then finally you'll get a message saying that page can't be shown.
所以如果你在北京使用谷歌，输入一个敏感的搜索词，比如“天安门广场”，你会得到全套搜索结果。但如果你试图点击任何政府屏蔽的链接，你的电脑就会变得异常缓慢。最后你会收到一条信息，显示该页面无法显示。
But things are different on other search engines. If you try Baidu or Bing or any other company that has its servers located on mainland China, lots of links come up, no matter what you search for. And you can access all the links.
但在其他搜索引擎上情况就不同了。如果你尝试百度或必应，或任何服务器位于中国大陆的公司，无论你搜索什么，都会出现大量链接。你也可以访问所有这些链接。
But only government-approved sites will show up. You can't tell what's missing. It's seamless. That's because the government distributes lists of forbidden subjects to all these companies and to China's version of Twitter, which is called Weibo. And it's the company's job to self-censor, or they risk being shut down.
但只有政府批准的网站才会显示。你无法分辨缺少了什么。它是无缝的。这是因为政府向所有这些公司以及中国版的Twitter（微博）分发禁忌主题列表。公司的任务是自我审查，否则他们面临关闭的风险。
Then there are also, as you've probably heard, thousands of people patrolling the web in China every day, some paid by the government, others by the websites themselves. They block and remove photos and films and articles. Even more scrubbing is done by automated programs that look for anything forbidden or suspicious.
然后正如你可能听说过的那样，每天有成千上万的人在中国巡视网络，一些受雇于政府，另一些受雇于网站本身。他们拦截并删除照片、电影和文章。更深层的清理是由自动程序完成的，它们寻找任何禁忌或可疑的内容。
Sometimes the government demands that a site hand over information about specific people and what they do online, with severe consequences. A journalist named Shi Tao is serving a 10-year sentence on charges of leaking state secrets, because Yahoo helped the government identify him through his email account. There are new cases all the time. More recently, a woman was sentenced to a year in a re-education through labor camp for forwarding a joke.
有时政府要求网站提交关于特定人员及其在线活动的信息，后果非常严重。一名叫师涛的记者因泄露国家机密被判入狱10年，因为雅虎通过他的电子邮件账号帮助政府识别了他的身份。新案件层出不穷。最近，一名女子因转发一个笑话被判入劳教所一年。
So when some Americans hear that internet companies like Baidu agree to all this in order to operate in China, they get mad. They want to hear that the company's fighting back. OK. Here's the reality, though.
所以当一些美国人听说百度这样的互联网公司为了在中国运营而同意所有这些条款时，他们会很生气。他们想听到的是公司在反击。好吧。但事实是这样的。
Yes, Baidu is the biggest, most powerful search engine in China. But the government is so vastly bigger and more powerful than Baidu or any other company or group of companies in the country. The government owns all the land, all the banks, all the TV stations, all the major newspapers. And it controls the army and the police. It does what it wants. And it doesn't have to care what anyone thinks. Here's Kaiser.
是的，百度是中国最大、最强大的搜索引擎。但政府比百度或该国的任何其他公司或公司集团要大得多、强大得多。政府拥有所有的土地、所有的银行、所有的电视台、所有的大型报纸。它控制着军队和警察。它想做什么就做什么。它不需要在意任何人的想法。这是Kaiser。
If you're not really profoundly conflicted by the things that you see here, then you just don't have your eyes open, right? I mean, living here as an expatriate, you're going to see things that will cause your blood to boil. But if you dwell in the house of indignation at all times, I mean, you're not going to hack it here.
如果你对在这里看到的事情不感到深深的冲突，那你就是没睁开眼睛，对吧？我的意思是，作为一个侨民住在这里，你会看到让你热血沸腾的事情。但如果你总是停留在愤怒的状态，那你在这里是混不下去的。
You hear versions of this all the time here, not only from expats, but from the Chinese themselves. To make it day-by-day in China, most people try to keep a narrow focus on the world in front of them. Improve what they can, without getting overwhelmed by the bigger picture.
在这里你总能听到各种版本的说法，不仅来自侨民，也来自中国人自己。为了在中国度过每一天，大多数人试图将狭隘的目光集中在眼前。在不被大局压垮的情况下，尽可能改善能改善的事情。
For an American epidemiologist I know, it means helping Chinese doctors fight the spread of HIV, even when the research draws on patients who've been rounded up by police. An American lawyer working to reform Chinese courts realized she couldn't start with the problem of torture in police custody. She had to start with an even more basic problem-- the fact that most people who go on trial never get a lawyer.
对我认识的一位美国流行病学家来说，这意味着帮助中国医生抗击艾滋病的传播，即使研究对象是那些被警察搜捕的患者。一位致力于改革中国法院的美国律师意识到，她不能从警察拘留中的虐待问题开始。她必须从一个更基本的问题开始——大多数受审者从未得到律师这一事实。
But no matter how careful anyone here is, the fact is that the lines are never clear when it comes to running afoul of the government. No matter how well someone understands China or how great their Chinese is, any expat or Chinese person can suddenly find themselves in a situation where they realize oh no.
但无论这里的任何人有多小心，事实是，当涉及到触犯政府时，界限永远不明确。无论某人对中国的理解有多深刻，或者中文有多好，任何侨民或中国人都会突然发现自己陷入了一种意识到“糟糕”的境地。
I overestimated my own ability to deal with a Leninist state.
我高估了自己应对列宁主义国家的能力。
This is Kaiser's friend Jeremy Goldkorn, the expat from South Africa who co-hosts the podcast with Kaiser. Jeremy is as smart and knowledgeable about China as almost anyone. He's lived here for 17 years.
这是Kaiser的朋友Jeremy Goldkorn，那位与Kaiser共同主持播客的南非侨民。Jeremy对中国的了解和知识几乎无人能及。他在这里住了17年。
And for a while, he had a groundbreaking website that covered Chinese media and the internet. It became huge. Until one day after six years, it was blocked in China, just gone forever. An entire career plan shut down.
有一段时间，他有一个开创性的网站，报道中国媒体和互联网。它非常火爆。直到六年后的某天，它在中国被屏蔽了，永远消失了。整个职业生涯规划就此终结。
It was Jeremy's Belgrade moment, his version of Kaiser's band break-up after the Peace Concert. Except Jeremy to this day has no idea what he did to be shut down. Which post or posts pushed his website over that line.
那是Jeremy的“贝尔格莱德时刻”，他版本的Kaiser在和平音乐会后的乐队解散。只不过Jeremy直到今天都不知道他做了什么被封杀。是哪一篇文章或哪些文章把他的网站推过了那条线。
The full set of rules the censors use are known only to the government. And the rules change constantly without notice. There's no book you can keep on your shelf and consult to avoid getting into trouble. And as Jeremy says, there's no hotline to call and ask, comrade, why did you censor my website?
审查员使用的全套规则只有政府知道。而且这些规则在没有通知的情况下不断变化。书架上没有一本书可以供你参考来避免惹麻烦。正如Jeremy所说，没有热线可以拨打来问：“同志，你为什么要审查我的网站？”
I mean I was always fairly cynical about China. But after that, there was a certain part of me which is like so this is the way it is here. And I was kidding myself thinking that I could just be daring enough to be interesting, but not daring enough to not really get into trouble. And it was do I stay or do I go. I think I was basically just quite numb for about a whole year, just not really knowing what to do.
我的意思是，我一直对中国相当愤世嫉俗。但在那之后，我内心有一部分就像是，“好吧，这里就是这样”。我是在欺骗自己，以为我可以足够大胆去变得有趣，但又不够大胆到真的惹上麻烦。于是就是我该留下还是离开。我想我基本上整整一年都是麻木的，真的不知道该做什么。
So you have these two friends, Jeremy and Kaiser, both Western expats in China, one of whom has found a way to coexist with the government censorship, and the other who got hammered by it. So it's not surprising that Jeremy's take on China's censorship regime is different from Kaiser's. Kaiser, like a lot of expats, says that he sees the present for what it is. But he sees momentum toward better things. Here's Jeremy's take.
所以你有这两个朋友，Jeremy和Kaiser，都是在中国的西方侨民，其中一个找到了与政府审查共存的方法，另一个则遭到了打击。所以Jeremy对中国审查制度的看法与Kaiser不同也就不足为奇了。Kaiser像许多侨民一样，说他眼见为实。但他看到了向好发展的势头。这是Jeremy的看法。
I mean, I broadly agree. But I think for the last two years, I've been a lot more pissed off about the censorship in China than he has. The things that should be black and white sometimes become a lot more blurry and a lot greyer. And people are less aware of the fact that there is, about certain things, a distinct difference between the way things are done here and elsewhere.
我的意思是，我大体上同意。但我认为在过去两年里，我对中国的审查制度比他更加恼火。那些应该是非黑即白的事情有时变得更加模糊和灰暗。人们对这样一个事实的意识减弱了：在某些事情上，这里的做法与其他地方有着明显的区别。
Yeah, I mean, this is where I think it gets really interesting. Because I feel the longer I'm here, that the more I'm comfortable saying, oh this is complicated. You got to understand the whole picture.
是的，我的意思是，我认为这正是最有趣的地方。因为我觉得我在这里待得越久，就越舒服地说道：“哦，这很复杂。你必须理解整个画面。”
And every once in while, a friend will stop me and say, wait a second. That's not complicated. It's just not OK to refer to internet censorship as internet regulations or internet management. And I do forget that. I mean I think I do.
偶尔，一位朋友会阻止我说：“等一下。这不复杂。将互联网审查称为‘互联网管理’或‘互联网监管’是不对的。”我确实会忘记这一点。我的意思是，我想我确实忘了。
Yeah, I know what you mean. I think once you get to know China, you do, yourself, tweak. You make allowances. You think that certain compromises are OK. It's a big country. There are too many people, too many poor people. It can't be run obviously the same as Norway or Sweden or even the United States.
是的，我知道你的意思。我想一旦你了解了中国，你自己就会调整。你会做出妥协。你认为某些妥协是可以接受的。这是一个大国。人口太多，穷人太多，显然不能和挪威、瑞典甚至美国以同样的方式运行。
I mean, I think it's one of the fundamental problems facing Chinese society right now is, the bar for everything is so low. Nobody's surprised that there's poison in the milk, because there is. And this is China, therefore that's the way it is. Therefore what are you going to do about it. And everybody's kind of fatalist.
我的意思是，我认为这是目前中国社会面临的基本问题之一，一切的标准都太低了。没有人会对牛奶里有毒感到惊讶，因为确实有。这是中国，所以情况就是这样。所以你能对此做什么呢。每个人都有点宿命论。
As an expat in China, when you hear yourself using a government-issued phrase like internet management, or chalking things up to China being complicated, it can feel like a failure. Or at least not the kind of understanding you set out to acquire. You spend so many years studying and adapting and trying to cross that chasm, to glimpse the world from the Chinese perspective, to finally get inside China. And when you reach the destination, you have to remember not to forget where you come from.
作为一个在中国的侨民，当你听到自己使用政府发放的短语如“互联网管理”，或者把事情归咎于“中国很复杂”时，这感觉像是一种失败。或者至少不是你原本打算获得的那种理解。你花了很多年去学习、适应并试图跨越那道鸿沟，从中国人的视角窥视世界，最终进入中国。当你到达目的地时，你必须记住不要忘记你来自哪里。
What are you making?
你在做什么？
Pancakes.
煎饼。
Kaiser's making breakfast for his two kids, seven-year-old Guinevere and six-year-old Johnny. His wife is Chinese, a native Beijinger he met while he was in Tang Dynasty. Kaiser's kids are growing up in China with a dad who talks to them all the time about the US, just like Kaiser's parents raised their kids in the US and talked to them all the time about China. Kaiser's dream is to someday live half the year in China and half the year in the United States.
Kaiser正在为他的两个孩子做早餐，七岁的Guinevere和六岁的Johnny。他的妻子是中国人，他在唐朝乐队时认识的北京本地人。Kaiser的孩子是在中国长大的，父亲总是跟他们谈论美国，就像Kaiser的父母在美国养育孩子并总是跟他们谈论中国一样。Kaiser的梦想是有朝一日能一年在中国住一半时间，在美国住一半时间。
But an even more basic dream of his is that the animosity between the two countries stops getting worse. He said that the main thing he loses sleep over now is the relationship between China and the United States. I asked him if he meant it literally, whether it really keeps him up.
但他更基本的梦想是两国之间的敌意不要再恶化了。他说他现在失眠的主要原因是中国和美国之间的关系。我问他这是字面意思吗，是真的让他彻夜难眠吗。
Yeah. It's literal. I mean it's-- one thing that I can't do before I go to bed is look at the comments sections on any story related to China, because of just the viciousness that you're now seeing on both sides. It's so depressing to watch this chasm opening up. I feel like the more they know about each other, essentially, the less they like each other.
是的。是字面意思。我的意思是——我睡觉前不能做的一件事就是看任何与中国相关的报道下的评论区，因为你现在在双方都能看到的恶毒。看着这道鸿沟裂开是如此令人沮丧。我觉得他们彼此了解得越多，本质上，他们就越不喜欢对方。
Kaiser has created a life for himself in China that ignores the chasm, a life where it all fits together. Americans who understand China, Chinese friends and family who understand the US. And especially his kids, on their way to being totally bilingual and as bi-cultural as he can make them. Looking at them it all seems possible. In that way, he's very Chinese and very American.
Kaiser在中国为自己创造了一种忽略鸿沟的生活，一种让一切合而为一的生活。了解中国的美国人，了解美国的中国朋友和家人。尤其是他的孩子，走在通往完全双语的道路上，并尽可能地让他们变得双文化。看着他们，一切似乎皆有可能。从这个意义上说，他既非常中国化，又非常美国化。
Evan Osnos. He's a staff writer at The New Yorker . And he writes a blog for them called "Letter from China."
Evan Osnos。《纽约客》的一名特约撰稿人。他为他们写了一个博客叫“来自中国的信”。
Coming up, the gossip in a tiny little village on the other side of the world. Our "Americans in China" show continues in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，世界另一端一个小村庄里的八卦。《在中国的美国人》节目一分钟后继续。来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Americans in China," what's it like to live there for years and years and what they see that we back home have not seen. We've arrived at Act Two of our program., Act Two, Beautiful Downtown Wasteland.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。当然，我们每周在节目中都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目，《在中国的美国人》，在那里生活多年是什么感觉，以及他们看到了我们家乡人没看到的东西。我们进入了节目的第二幕，第二幕，“美丽的市中心废土”。
There are so few farmers in the United States that in 1993, the census stopped counting the number of Americans who live on farms. At the time, less than 2% of the population lived on a farm. Less than 1% now works full-time as farmers.
美国农民很少，以至于1993年人口普查停止统计住在农场里的美国人数。当时，只有不到2%的人口住在农场。不到1%的人全职从事农业。
But in China, despite the vast migration to cities in recent years, more than half the country, half of all people in China, live on farms or rural areas. Michael Meyer is a writer whose first book, The Last Days of Old Beijing , detailed his three years living in Beijing's oldest neighborhood. Lately, though, he's been writing about living in rural China, specifically in the village that his wife comes from.
但在中国，尽管近年来大规模向城市迁移，但超过一半的国家，即所有中国人中有一半，居住在农场或农村地区。Michael Meyer是一位作家，他的第一本书《旧北京的最后日子》详细记录了他居住在北京最古老街区的三年生活。不过最近，他一直在写关于在中国农村生活的故事，特别是他妻子出生的那个村庄。
In the movie Caddyshack , Rodney Dangerfield says that he and his partner Wang bought some property behind the Great Wall-- "on the good side." Manchuria, where I live, is on the other side, a place where exiles were once sent to the land beyond the pale. Today, the region bordered by Mongolia, North Korea, and Siberia, is more prosaically called Dongbei, the Northeast. And I live at its heart in a village named Wasteland.
在电影《疯狗高尔夫》中，罗德尼·丹杰菲尔德说他和搭档王在长城后面买了一些房产——“在好的一边”。我住的满洲在另一边，曾经是流放者被送往荒凉之地的地方。今天，这个与蒙古、朝鲜和西伯利亚接壤的地区，更通俗地被称为东北。我住在它的心脏地带，一个叫“废土”的村庄。
It's actually quite beautiful. Two dozen homes that in summer look afloat on emerald green rice paddies and bound by a sea of snow in winter, when temperatures fall to -20 and the sun goes down before 4:00.
它实际上很美。二三十户人家，夏天看起来漂浮在翠绿的稻田上，冬天则被雪海包围，气温降至零下20度，太阳在4点前就下山了。
No one can say for certain where the name Wasteland comes from. It could be a trick to keep away outsiders. Wasteland's neighboring villages include places named Lonely Outpost, Jong's Smelly Ditch, The Dunes, and Mudtown. There's also Big Wasteland, where they grow organic rice and whose residents consider themselves a cut above. I never go to Big Wasteland. That's the funny thing about a village-- no matter how small, it becomes your entire world.
没有人能肯定“废土”这个名字从何而来。可能是为了阻挡外人的伎俩。废土的邻村包括叫“孤独前哨”、“宗的臭水沟”、“沙丘”和“泥城”的地方。还有一个“大废土”，他们种植有机水稻，那里的居民认为自己高人一等。我从不去“大废土”。这就是村庄的有趣之处——无论多小，它都成了你的整个世界。
Wasteland is a bedroom community of sorts. There are no traffic lights or even stop signs out here. Just single-story brick homes backed by outhouses, and two corner stores which double as mah-jong parlors at the intersection of Red Flag Road. Lonely Outpost is where the nearest services are. In a town of 1,500 people, three miles south, where I volunteer as an English teacher at the middle school.
废土算是个卧室社区。这里没有红绿灯，甚至没有停车标志。只有砖房，后面是茅房，在红旗路的交叉口有两个小卖部，兼作麻将室。孤独前哨是最近的提供服务的地方。那是个1500人的城镇，在南面三英里处，我在那里的中学当志愿者英语老师。
The walk there from Wasteland takes me past the anti-aircraft gun used to seed clouds for rain and the new organic farm slash hot spring resort that fills with city folk on weekends. There's a Christian church, feed and fertilizer stores, a bank, and a shop selling tabloids and self-published circulars with titles such as Intriguing Stories and Strange Affairs.
从废土走到那里，会经过用来人工降雨的高射炮，以及周末挤满城里人的新有机农场加温泉度假村。那里有一个基督教堂、饲料和化肥店、一家银行，以及一家出售小报和自出版传单的商店，标题如《引人入胜的故事》和《怪事》。
It answers questions such as will our capital be moved from Beijing? No. Did the 1989 student protest movement fail? Yes. And how many people were killed during the Cultural Revolution? Lots.
它回答了诸如“我们的首都将从北京迁走吗？”（不）。“1989年学生抗议运动失败了吗？”（是的）。以及“文化大革命期间有多少人被杀？”（很多）。
When a stranger sees me walking, the first question is not what country am I from, but [SPEAKING CHINESE], to which family do I belong? The Fangs, I say. My in-laws still hold title to land here. And it's where my wife spent her childhood. She now works as an attorney in Hong Kong, and I shuttle between China's far north and far south to be together.
当陌生人看到我走路时，第一个问题不是我来自哪个国家，而是“[说中文]，属于哪个家庭？”我说“方家”。我的姻亲在这里还拥有土地所有权。这是我妻子度过童年的地方。她现在在香港当律师，我和她在中国的最北端和最南端之间穿梭以便相聚。
This arrangement, of course, is a big topic of conversation for other Wastelanders. They can fill hours talking about other people's lives, punctuated with dialect such as "enna" for "yes," and for gasps "ay-ya, wat a my-ah" literally "oh, my mother." They tell me all about my wife's past, hector me about my present, and speculate on our future. Ay-ya wat a my-ah, they say. When are you going to be a father? Enna, you can't do it from up here, when she's down there.
这种安排当然是废土人谈论的一大话题。他们可以花几个小时谈论别人的生活，中间穿插着像“嗯那”这样的方言表示“是的”，还有表示惊叹的“哎呀，我的妈呀”。他们告诉我关于我妻子过去的一切，训诫我的现在，并推测我们的未来。“哎呀，我的妈呀，”他们说，“你什么时候当爸爸？嗯那，她在那儿，你在这里是做不到的。”
In urban China, the sight of a foreigner no longer causes a crowd to gather and stare. But in the rural half, people still approach me with friendly, cautious curiosity, the way you might if a giraffe wandered down your street. I read that the comedian Steve Martin used to hand autograph seekers a signed name card that confirmed the person had met Steve Martin and found him to be warm, polite, intelligent, and funny. I've often thought of making a similar card to present with a silent smile, answering the usual six questions asked of me in this order.
在中国城市里，看到一个外国人不再会引起人群聚集和注视。但在农村那一半地区，人们仍然友好、谨慎地向我走来，就像长颈鹿走进你的街道一样。我读到喜剧演员史蒂夫·马丁过去常给索要签名的人一张签名的名片，确认此人见过史蒂夫·马丁并发现他温暖、礼貌、聪明且风趣。我常想做一张类似的卡片，带着沉默的微笑递过去，回答他们依次问我的六个问题。
One, I'm an American. Two, I've been in China a long time. Three, I was born in the Year of the Rat. I'm 1.86 meters tall. Four, I do not have a salary. I'm a writer. Five, Chinese is not hard. It is easier to learn than English. Six, yes, I can use chopsticks. We eat Chinese food in America too, but often it's expensive and orange.
一，我是美国人。二，我在中国待了很久。三，我是鼠年出生的。我身高1.86米。四，我没有工资。我是个作家。五，中文不难。比学英语容易。六，是的，我会用筷子。我们在美国也吃中餐，但通常很贵，而且是橙色的。
On rare occasions, someone starts me off with a curve ball. A gruff construction worker sidled up to me last week, hard helmet in hand, to ask if anyone has ever told me my beard is beautiful. Once, a gentleman in a business suit, standing on a country lane, wondered if morality was more important than wisdom.
在极少数情况下，有人会用曲线球让我措手不及。上周，一个粗犷的建筑工人带着安全帽向我走来，问是否有人告诉过我我的胡子很漂亮。曾经，一个身穿西装的绅士站在乡村小路上，想知道道德是否比智慧更重要。
When I arrived in China 17 years ago as one of the country's first Peace Corps volunteers, I actually couldn't use chopsticks and spoke Spanish, not Chinese. The first sentence I learned to say was [SPEAKING CHINESE], I'm an American.
17年前，作为中国第一批和平队员之一，我刚到中国时实际上根本不会用筷子，说的是西班牙语而不是中文。我学会说的第一句话是“[说中文]，我是美国人。”
In Wasteland, the words still elicit a smile and the assertion that America, mei-guo, literally "the beautiful country" is just that and very rich and very powerful. While China is still backward, but developing and also would invade countries for oil if it could. And is it true that American farmers own their own land?
在废土，这些话依然会引起微笑，并断言美国，meiguo，字面意思是“美丽的国家”，就是那样，非常富有，非常强大。而中国依然落后，但在发展，如果可能的话，也会为了石油入侵国家。美国农民真的拥有自己的土地吗？
But along with admiration for the US, there's also admonition. Last week, a farmer on a bus sitting with his chicken between us announced, "Nixon was the best president your country ever had. It's been bad ever since." I am asked why my president bullies other countries and meddles with Taiwan. People wonder in the same wounded tone why the American Indians were pushed off their lands, and why Lebron James left Cleveland to play for the Miami Heat.
但在钦佩美国的同时，也有训诫。上周，巴士上一位坐着，两腿间夹着鸡的农民宣布：“尼克松是你国历史上最好的总统。从那以后就不行了。”我被问到为什么我的总统欺负其他国家并插手台湾事务。人们用同样受伤的语气想知道为什么美国印第安人被赶出他们的土地，以及为什么勒布朗·詹姆斯离开克利夫兰去为迈阿密热火队效力。
I laugh at these assumptions, but compared to what Americans ask me when I say I live in China, it sometimes makes me wonder which is the developing country. But China is far, Americans often say. How can you live so far away? The Chinese are different than us, Americans often assert. But they want to be like us, right? They are the next superpower. And most passionately, they ask what about the toilets?
我嘲笑这些假设，但与我回答说住在中国时美国人问我的问题相比，这有时让我怀疑哪个才是发展中国家。但“中国很远”，美国人经常说。“你怎么能住得那么远？”“中国人跟我们不一样，”美国人断言。“但他们想变得像我们一样，对吧？他们是下一个超级大国。”最热切的是，他们问厕所怎么办？
Stop, I reply. China is not far. Nowhere is far with Skype and nonstop flights. Chinese are just as self-effacing as Americans and have a similar sense of humor.
停，我回答。中国不远。有了Skype和直飞航班，哪里都不远。中国人跟美国人一样自谦，也有类似的幽默感。
China is the next superpower? Wake me when urban tap water is drinkable, when an ambulance will come when called and can make it through traffic, and when there's transparency in government, law, and the finance sector, to say nothing of a civil society, environmental protections, freedom of speech, and-- but usually by now, the questioner's eyes have glazed over. And I miss being asked simple questions, such as whether I can use chopsticks.
“中国是下一个超级大国？”等城市自来水可以喝，等救护车在呼叫时能来并且能穿过交通，等政府、法律和金融领域有透明度，更不用说公民社会、环境保护、言论自由时再叫醒我——但通常这时候，提问者已经眼神呆滞了。而且我怀念被问到简单问题的时候，比如我是否会用筷子。
Lately, people in Wasteland ask me about the economic crisis and if that is why I live in China. Echoes of when Chinese felt sorry for me as a Peace Corps volunteer, wondering what sort of country sends its young people overseas to work with strangers.
最近，废土的人问我关于经济危机，问那是不是我住在中国的原因。这回响着当我是和平队员时，中国人为我感到难过，纳闷是什么样的国家派它的年轻人到海外与陌生人一起工作。
China is clamoring to reduce its rural population and urbanize. Previously, farm workers migrated to cities. But now the city is coming to them, through an expansion of municipal borders. Wasteland was recently added to the Guilin city limits.
中国正吵着要减少农村人口并城市化。以前，农场工人迁移到城市。但现在，城市通过市政边界的扩张走向了他们。废土最近被划入了桂林市界。
A new billboard towers over Red Flag Road pledging to "build the Northeast top village." A few months ago, workers had gone all through the night pouring cement under klieg lights to finish widening Red Flag. The new road is double its previous width, and as straight and smooth as a runaway. City cars and tour buses heading to the hot spring resorts speed down it at 60 miles an hour leaving a jet stream of trash-- empty Panda Brand cigarette boxes, and bottles of rice wine, along with broad sheets of stock tips, real estate flyers, and fortunetelling booklets.
一块新的广告牌矗立在红旗路上，承诺“建设东北第一村”。几个月前，工人们彻夜在聚光灯下浇注水泥，完成了红旗路的拓宽工作。新路是以前宽度的两倍，像跑道一样平坦笔直。开往温泉度假村的城市汽车和旅游巴士以每小时60英里的速度疾驰而过，留下一串垃圾——空的熊猫牌香烟盒、米酒瓶，以及大张的股票建议、房地产传单和算命手册。
Villagers, however, are concerned with other signs, like the ones advertising Eastern Fortune Rice, a privately held and government-backed local business that built the hot spring resort. It's also buying locals' rice crop and hiring them as laborers.
然而，村民们关心的是其他迹象，比如广告“东方福米”的那些，那是一家私营且有政府支持的当地企业，建立了温泉度假村。它也在购买当地人的水稻作物并雇佣他们作为劳工。
My older neighbors worry that their paddies, once farmed collectively as a commune then tilled independently, may slip from their control and into the hands of the company. A rumor has it that even Wasteland's name will change to Eastern Fortune.
我的老邻居担心他们曾经作为公社集体耕种、后来独立耕作的水稻田可能会脱离他们的控制，落入该公司手中。有传言说连废土的名字都要改成“东方福”。
In Wasteland for the first time, a skyline is taking shape. There are cranes and the shells of five-story walk-up buildings. Eastern Fortune Rice is offering apartments in exchange for farmers' homes, which will be razed and the land converted to paddies, leased by the company for an annual fee.
在废土，天际线第一次成形了。有起重机和五层步梯楼的壳子。东方福米正以公寓换取农民的住宅，这些住宅将被拆除，土地转为水稻田，由该公司租赁，每年支付费用。
The project's billboard shows a pearling stream, renamed the Revered Gentry River, crowned with lotuses, bordered by willow trees and apartments featuring indoor plumbing and central heat. The people in this future scene sit on benches and stroll under trellises with children and lovers, wearing blouses and skirts and t-shirts and jeans. They look and act nothing like Wastelanders, at least not yet.
项目的广告牌显示了一条珍珠般的小溪，更名为“敬绅河”，上面簇拥着莲花，柳树环绕，公寓配有室内管道和中央供暖。未来场景中的人们坐在长椅上，在棚架下带着孩子和恋人漫步，穿着衬衫、裙子、T恤和牛仔裤。他们看起来和行为举止一点都不像废土人，至少现在还不像。
Through marriage, I have various distant relatives in Wasteland. The one I'm closest to is Sanjo. I have known Sanjo for a decade. He is 67, a rice farmer, and the head of a household that includes his wife, three children, and assorted grandchildren and cousins. The door of his one-story home is often banging open and shut from visitors. And the white pekingese that keeps watch out front has barked itself hoarse on occasion.
通过婚姻，我在废土有各种远房亲戚。我最亲近的是三舅。我已经认识三舅十年了。他67岁，是个稻农，是一家之主，家里包括妻子、三个孩子以及各式各样的孙子和表亲。他那平房的门经常因为访客而砰砰作响。看门的白色北京狗有时吠得声嘶力竭。
Last summer, Sanjo had a stroke. Two fingers on his left hand went numb. And he walked to the clinic in Lonely Outpost.
去年夏天，三舅中风了。左手两个手指麻木了。他走到孤独前哨的诊所。
I was out of town when this happened. And on my first day back, I woke at 6:00 in the morning and walked the mile to his home to find Sanjo had already biked to the clinic for a daily dose of medicine. I walked two miles to the clinic.
发生这种情况时我不在城里。我回来的第一天，清晨6点起床，步行一英里到他家，发现三舅已经骑车去诊所拿每日的药物了。我步行两英里到诊所。
Young nurses in starched white uniforms I had only seen on television shows as a kid ask the usual questions. And I roam the hall looking in doors for Sanjo, robotically replying American, a long time, Year of the Rat, 1.86 meters tall.
穿着我儿时在电视节目上才看到的浆洗过的白制服的年轻护士问那些常规问题。我在大厅里徘徊，在门里寻找三舅，机械地回答：“美国人，待了很久，鼠年出生，身高1.86米。”
Sanjo lay in a room with four platform beds, each occupied by a man on his back tethered to an IV line. A ceiling fan pushed the limpid air, and flies buzzed against the screen windows facing the village street. Rumbling dump trucks blared their horns as they passed, sending plumes of dust into the room. When the saline bag emptied, a patient yelled at the top of his voice [SPEAKING CHINESE], change medicine.
三舅躺在一个有四张平台床的房间里，每张床上都有一个男人仰卧着，连接着静脉注射管。吊扇推动着沉闷的空气，苍蝇在对着村道的纱窗上嗡嗡作响。轰鸣的自卸卡车驶过时发出喇叭声，在房间里掀起一阵灰尘。当盐水袋空了，一个病人大声喊着“[说中文]，换药。”
Sanjo's eyes lit up as I said hello and patted his arm. There's no hugging in Chinese families. A man with a hand bandaged in white gauze slung around his neck asked where I had gone for a week. And I said to write about California, where airplanes seed rice paddies from the sky. The men were skeptical and silent, before one who had taken a liquor bottle to the eyebrow shouted [SPEAKING CHINESE]. A starched nurse entered and said, our clinic must look really poor to an American. The kind of reflexive embarrassment a foreigner often hears in China.
当我说你好并拍拍他的手臂时，三舅的眼睛亮了。中国家庭里没有拥抱。一个手上缠着白纱布挂在脖子上的男人问我这一周去了哪里。我说去写关于加州的故事，那里的飞机在天空中播种稻田。男人们怀疑而沉默，直到一个用酒瓶砸中眉毛的人喊道“[说中文]”。一位浆洗过的护士进来，说：“我们的诊所对美国人来说一定看起来很穷。”这是外国人常在中国听到的那种反射性的尴尬。
The Chinese countryside is beautiful, but poverty is poverty, no matter how picturesque. And Lonely Outpost Clinic is, by all measures, poor. But it is also well supplied, attentively staffed, and affordable even for a farmer. Still I wanted to pay for Sanjo's care, but how could I say, in a room full of people, that he should not worry about the bill?
中国农村很美，但贫穷就是贫穷，无论多么风景如画。孤独前哨诊所各方面来说都很穷。但它也供应充足、人员细心，即便是对农民来说也负担得起。但我还是想为三舅的护理付费，但在一个满是人的房间里，我怎么能说他不应该担心账单呢？
Paying in China represents more than a financial transaction. Merely picking up a restaurant check often leads to tableside scrums, climaxing with hand slapping dashes to the register to toss down money first. Paying is a show of respect and a deposit in the ledger of favors that balances relationships.
在中国付账代表的不仅仅是财务交易。仅仅是结清餐厅账单往往会导致桌边的争执，高潮是互相拍手抢着冲向收银台先扔钱。付账是尊重的表现，也是平衡关系的人情账簿中的存款。
As a newcomer, let alone a foreigner, this account is all but closed to me. Sanjo knew the men in the room his entire life. He lived through six decades of history with them.
作为新来者，更不用说外国人，这个账户对我来说基本是关闭的。三舅认识房间里的男人们一辈子了。他和他们一起经历了六十年的历史。
When I meet people in the Northeast and get around to asking their age-- it's not polite to ask an older person directly-- I immediately subtract the number from the current year and flip through a mental history book of what the person has lived through, with chapter headings that include Chinese Warlords, Japanese Occupiers, and the Puppet State of Manchukuo. Soviet soldiers, and then the Communists and campaigns such as land reform, the Resist-America Aid-Korea War, the Great Leap Forward, and collective farming.
当我在东北遇到人并开始问他们的年龄时——直接问老人年龄不礼貌——我会立刻从当前年份减去那个数字，并翻阅一本心理历史书，看看那个人经历了什么，章节标题包括“中国军阀”、“日本占领者”和“伪满洲国”。苏联士兵，然后是共产党和诸如土地改革、“抗美援朝”、大跃进和集体耕作等运动。
Those bold headings can blur the individual lives lived in between. The sister of my housemate, Mr. Guan, once pointed at the water well in our backyard and casually said our father was a teacher and threw himself down that during the Cultural Revolution.
那些粗体的标题可能会模糊掉中间生活的个体生命。我室友关先生的姐姐曾经指着我们后院的水井，轻描淡写地说我们父亲以前是个老师，在文化大革命期间投进去了。
And that's when I get lost in China, still, despite knowing the language and culture, and, frankly, I know more about this region's geography and history than many locals. But I haven't lived it, and so will always be apart.
而那正是我在中国的失落之处，仍然，尽管知道语言和文化，而且说实话，我对这个地区的地理和历史比许多当地人都了解得多。但我没有亲历过，所以永远是局外人。
My opinion, my very being, can be deleted by anyone, even a four-year-old child, with a simple [SPEAKING CHINESE], you don't understand. [SPEAKING CHINESE], you are a foreigner. Well, duh, I think. But it's true. I'll often miss these unspoken cues-- when to pay, how to pay, when to praise, when to criticize, when to curse, when to laugh-- that may not impact that day, but may alter the ones to come.
我的观点，我的整个存在，可能会被任何人，甚至是一个四岁的孩子，用简单的“[说中文]，你不懂。[说中文]，你是外国人”给删除。好吧，我想，你说得对。但这确实是真的。我经常会错过这些未言明的暗示——何时付账、如何付账、何时赞美、何时批评、何时诅咒、何时欢笑——这可能不会影响那天，但可能会改变以后的日子。
Like my visit to the clinic, after which Sanjo's family let it be known, via a third party, that I was not welcome for our usual weekly dinner at their home. Why? Was it about money? About face? About a joke I made or something the clinic staff said? I was, and remain, baffled. But this is common in a village, where resentments steep like tea leaves.
就像我访问诊所，在那之后，三舅的家人通过第三方表示，我们通常在他家进行的周晚餐我不受欢迎。为什么？是因为钱吗？因为面子？因为我开了个玩笑，还是诊所工作人员说了什么？我当时感到，现在依然感到困惑。但这在村里很常见，怨恨像茶叶一样浸泡。
The next day I carefully mention the encounter to a neighbor. Social networks are still analog here. She clucked and said, everyone calls Sanjo "chod-sze"-- slippery. That's been his nickname for decades. You can never tell what's going on with him. Just go back to his house and pretend nothing happened.
第二天，我小心翼翼地向邻居提到了这次遭遇。这里的社交网络仍然是模拟的。她咯咯笑着说：“大家都叫三舅‘滑头’。那个绰号已经用了几十年了。你永远不知道他到底在想什么。你就回他家去，假装什么都没发生就行了。”
So I did, carrying as an offering a bag of Lonely Outpost luxuries such as Oreos, peaches, and chrysanthemum tea. Nothing was explained, but that night I ate dinner seated next to a friendly Sanjo on his kang, munching flash fried pork and garlic stems, while kids ran in and out, the door slammed and the Pekinese tried its best to be heard.
所以我就去了，带去了一袋孤独前哨的奢侈品，比如奥利奥、桃子和菊花茶。什么都没解释，但那天晚上我坐在三舅炕上，吃着快炒猪肉和蒜苔，孩子们跑进跑出，门砰砰作响，北京狗尽其所能让人听到它的吠声。
Like teachers, writers are worthy of pity in China, even out in the sticks. But I know the trouble my presence causes, cutting a wake across the surface of village life. China's distrusts the single traveler, the person without a work unit or even a name card, especially when the person is a la-wai, an old outsider, as foreigners are often called. And with reason-- we can always leave.
像老师一样，作家在中国是值得同情的，即使在穷乡僻壤。但我知道我的出现引起了麻烦，在村庄生活的表面上划出了一道涟漪。中国不信任单身旅行者，没有工作单位甚至没有名片的人，尤其是当此人是“老外”——正如外国人常被称呼的那样。而且有理由——我们随时可以离开。
Chinese doesn't use tenses or differentiate between singular and plural. So one la-wai is the same as six la-wai. But in situations such as this, in a town so small, where I am a visitor, teaching, sure, and invited to weddings and funerals and New Year's dinners, but a guest always. I know how to describe my numbers. Just as there is a murder of crows and a school of fish, in China, even in the middle of Wasteland, the foreigner is always a hassle of la-wai.
中文不使用时态，也不区分单复数。所以一个老外和六个老外是一样的。但在这种情况下，在这么小的镇子上，我是个访问者，教书，当然，被邀请参加婚礼、葬礼和新年晚餐，但永远是个客人。我知道如何描述我的数字。正如有一群乌鸦和一所鱼，在中国，即使是在废土的中心，外国人永远是一群麻烦的老外。
Michael Meyer, reading excerpts adapted from the book that he's writing about life in rural China. It's called In Manchuria. And it will be published later this year.
Michael Meyer，朗读改编自他正在写的关于中国农村生活书中的节选。书名是《在满洲》。它将于今年晚些时候出版。
Well, our program was produced today by Miki Meek, our senior producer Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Matt Kielty, music help from Damien Graef, from Rob Geddes.
嗯，我们的节目今天由Miki Meek、我们的资深制作人Julie Snyder制作，Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Sarah Koenig、Jonathan Menjivar、Lisa Pollak、Brian Reed、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike参与。Seth Lind是我们的制作经理。Emily Condon是我们的办公室经理。Matt Kielty提供了制作帮助，Damien Graef和Rob Geddes提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, we keep trying to get our program onto the BBC. And we have these meetings with executives at the BBC. And Torey ruins every single meeting by blurting out in the middle--
《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板Torey Malatia先生负责。你知道，我们一直试图让我们的节目进入BBC。我们和BBC的高管开过这些会议。Torey在中间脱口而出，毁掉了每一次会议——
Oh, they're so cute. Oh, look at that cute foreigner. That's so adorable.
哦，他们太可爱了。哦，看那个可爱的外国人。真可爱。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。